good evening congratulations first and
foremost i feel like about 20 years in
the making we've waited for this sequel
now we're back in san francisco
celebrating how does it feel for you
it's uh
it's pretty exciting pretty amazing no
it's amazing um it's cool you know we
filmed here so it's great to be back
um
you know it was a wonderful experience
making the film and you know to have the
premiere and to have it opening it's
very exciting
and
yeah hopefully people will enjoy the
film and uh
yeah we're not going to do so many of
these so much so it's really cool to be
able to have
an event around i feel such a special
film yeah yeah i agree with you
wholeheartedly um
one of your co-stars priyanka shared a
little story of how nice of a guy you
were to her on set she was dealing with
a scene that made her a little nervous
and she was able to carry through and
you spoke some words to her what do you
make of that nice guy thing that
everybody says about you uh
i don't know nice is nice right so
that's nice um other than that i don't
know what to say but
thank you talk to me about the marvel
franchise you mentioned that you love to
get in it where yeah if i could just use
my imagination anywhere where do you fit
in who do you work with
oh my gosh
i don't know
i don't know
i don't i actually don't have an answer
for that question we would do anything
to see you in the mcu that would be
incredible well that's kind of you to
say man you know i mean there's so many
wonderful films and and filmmakers and
artists participating in those films it
would be uh
it would be fun to be a part of it
somebody just told me about you jumped
off a uh in one of the scenes 19 times
like 46 stories tell me about that
yeah carrie anne moss who plays trinity
i was playing neo and uh there's a
moment where we're trying to
survive and so we kind of took a leap a
lover's leap let's say off of a building
19 times yeah it was about 45 stories
wow and it's one of the cool things
about the matrix is that you get to do
some uh
some fun stuff yeah well look i need to
let you get out of here i want to ask
one more thing sandra bullock said she'd
love to re-team with you at some point
on a comedy what are your thoughts on
that that sounds like a absolutely fine
idea
sandra
yes thank you
[Music]
you